- Okay, so let me start by thinking.
Cause that was quite an
extraordinary piece of documentary.
If I may say, first my
personal impression,
the impression of being,
having been able to
concentrating only half an hour.
All the issues that are
concerned with this debate,
let's call it a debate,
between the receiving
countries and the people
that come from other countries
and try to cross the borders.
There are many, many
suggestions in your documentary.
Let me start from my own
angle, if you allow me, Mauro.
My angle is the European Union.
I am an official European
Union and fellow here.
And the European Union was
mentioned several times
in your documentary, sort of
a present and absent actor.
Although what we have seen
represents very much similar
situation in other parts of the world.
But let's concentrate on
why the European Union
is an actor and actually is an actor
by presence and absence.
I will try to be very brief on that,
but it seems to be important.
While I was starting,
I opened the treaty of
European Union in front of me.
And I will start by reading
out the first sentence
of article two of that treaty
that says that the Union
is founded on the values
of respect for human dignity, freedom,
democracy, equality,
the rule of law and
respect for human rights,
including the rights of person
belonging to minorities.
What we have seen here
is a direct challenge
to these expression of values.
I see the challenges on several aspects.
The first challenge is about the safety
of these people at sea.
Cause this is an island.
And we know that there is an ongoing
tragedy in the Mediterranean.
Not only in that part
of the Mediterranean,
also in the Igena area.
A lot of refugees are
dying trying to cross from
the Turkish coasts to the
Greek Islands, for example.
So, this is about international
law and shared values
of all the world, all
the states of the world.
There is a clear, an
existent law of the sea
since at least 150, 2,000, 200 years.
That puts the safeguard
of life at sea at the top
of every kind of action in the sea.
So it, when somebody is saved at sea,
that person must be brought to the,
to the mainland and protected.
That has been the civilization
for all the countries
in the world.
What we are seeing,
and there is some perception here
beyond this lip service to saving lives.
There is always a sentence
that refers to "but."
Saving lives, but you have to
do this, you have to do that.
This but represents actually a refrain
from implementing those principles
of ward understanding of what should be
the protection of life.
The second element is the
element that I perceived in this,
in this documentary is the separation
between the human being
and his or her rights.
Many of the interviews focused
on the belonging to a group.
If you belong to a certain
group, then you are welcome.
If you do not belong to
a certain, to that group,
you are no longer welcome.
That belonging, it is not
clear who should decide
on what that belonging means,
but certainly that requirement
or conditions to belonging
is in breach of the values
of respect of human dignity,
equality, rule of law, and
respect for human rights.
Why? Because human rights
are individual human rights
and respect for human dignity
is the respect of the dignity
of each individual,
not only if they are
part of a wider group,
be it religious or national.
So, and the third element,
and I will stop here,
and the third element is the
conflict between interests.
It is interesting from
this documentary that
there are two levels of
interests in competition here.
On the one hand, we hear
certain interveners stating
that there is an interest for Malta
and for the European countries to have
more and better immigration.
Because we need skillful and
even unskilled labor forces.
So, we need these people
to move to our countries.
At the same time, the interest,
that interest is opposed
by those, we heard that,
that make, coincide the
interest of the country
with the security of the country.
Security means sealing the borders.
There is an interesting question,
which is asked by one of the interveners,
why the war ships that are
crossing the Mediterranean
in front that are preventing,
that the weapons are smuggled into Libya,
that has a terrible civil war ongoing.
They do not save people at
sea, that was the question.
Well, the answer may
lie in other interveners
that have said that what
they are interested in is
protecting the country,
meaning creating a hard border,
separating that country from the rest.
This is not only the Mediterranean,
you may have an equal on
what happens in this country
and in other countries in the world.
So Mauro, I will stop here.
I detected these three
possible lines of exchange,
or in any event, these are
my comments at this time.
- Yeah, for me, as you
might have realized,
this documentary that we,
I say we because I didn't do
the documentary just by myself,
I did it with Nunzio Gringeri,
which is a great colleague
and that's a very good friend of mine.
We tried to show something different
that is in the published discussion.
When we talk about migration and refugees,
we usually, this is something
that I also explored
in my work in the past, a very
emotional image of migrants.
So usually when we read that, for example,
on a newspaper about migrants,
we read when they arrive
and when they are drowned.
We never read about
migrants, about their life.
What are they doing in Europe,
about the detention center.
The only way for these human beings
to be somehow, to find someone
interested in their life
is when they finally arrive to Europe.
And we usually call them an invasion.
Or where they don't arrive,
because unfortunately they're drowned.
And the idea of this documentary
was to work on two different levels.
On one level was to show the migrant,
and they would like them to
come back on this definition,
because we had a discussion previously.
And this is interesting
also to talk a bit about
what we talk about when
we talk about migrants,
refugees, asylum seekers.
We should never forget that first of all,
they're human beings.
So, the idea was to
show these human beings,
not as people coming from another planet,
but just as other human
beings like everyone else
in the documentary.
In the past, in my documentaries,
I was inevitably also
because of the context
that the documentaries were
realized were refugee camps,
focusing a bit more on their condition.
Now, I had the idea to
put them at the same level
with all the other people
that was interviewed.
And then the most important
part of the documentary is to
focus on the effects that the
perception that we developed
in the last 11 years since 2011,
when the so called Arab Spring started.
And we had all this new phenomenon of
arrivals reaching Europe.
It's how this perception
actually had a very strong
development in the political life.
And then on the social perception
that we have in Europe,
you can see this in the
documentary in different ways.
There is something that at
some point Eric Mooney say,
he mentioned that if actually
the African population
will decide to truly invade Europe,
there will be one to 1.2 billion people.
This would be impossible to stop.
And I think this sentence,
what you say is very important,
because it gives us an image,
a clear image of how wrong
is our published discussion
about this phenomenon.
We continue to stick to
this idea of invasion of
something that is gonna change our culture
because we are gonna be outnumbered by
these human beings arriving.
And when we truly look at the numbers,
when we truly look at the social effects
that these arrivals really made,
it's mostly a political construction
and it's a political
construction that we can see
very well in the documentary,
both with this strange
couple saying absurd things
and with these men from the popular party
because they are perfectly the
expression of the political
effects of this phenomenon.
It's, I always, every time that
I see again the documentary,
I can't help but to have
a very mixed feeling
when this strange couple of friends talk.
Because at some point, it
happened in a few screenings
that people ask me if these two people,
they were for real or they were actors.
Because at some point, it
seems a bit that they are
playing a screenplay because it's,
it sounds just impossible
that they really think-
At some point the men say, "Why
are they coming from Syria?
There's no war in Syria."
And I mean, being there listening to that,
when he told us was a bit an absurd.
So I, our goal was to
show a bit these effects
and to try also to concretely
address one of the main
problems that as European union,
we saw in the last 11 years in connection
with the migration phenomenon.
Which is how the political,
many parties on the
European political scenario,
used something that is just a phenomenon,
is not a problem.
And that concretely has no
particularly importance on the
economical, political, social
development of our countries.
Not for bad, at least
maybe could be for good.
And they transformed
this phenomenon in full
for their movements.
And we are seeing this
everywhere in Europe.
And unfortunately, I
had the sensation that
unless something change,
we will continue to
see that in the future.
Probably not just in Europe
because as you know very well,
this has been used very similarly
also in the United States.
- Let me add another layer,
which is sparked by your
own comments, Mauro.
You link, rightly, the
increase in the worsening
of the situation to the Arab Spring.
This is another paradox
of this debate because the
so-called Arab Spring or spring phenomena,
cause there are many different,
different expressions of that phenomenon,
in the beginning of the 2010s.
They can be maybe summarily
summarized by the,
finally in some countries,
some democratic conscience
that has been expressed
through the people taking the streets,
asking for a change of the government,
requesting the change of
the structure of the state.
Although, now the situation is worsened.
The best evolution that
we saw was Tunisia.
Tunisia went through this.
There was a dictator, which was thrown out
and then some riots and then elections,
and then a truly democratic,
although complicated debate,
in the state and then a new constitution.
Now we are in a bad turn,
I don't know how it will,
how it will evolve in the
future, but we have to seal this
and where is the
contradiction of the parks?
Because we sort of blame
the persons that have been
liberated by all these
phenomena, all these explosions,
social and political explosions,
for having done so and having
taken their own freedom
and their own lives in their own hands
and tried to move in
places where they could
have a better life.
So paradoxically, we claim that
we defend democracy at home,
but as soon as democracy
produces unsettlement,
diversions, complications
in the near border,
the only thing we think we
should do is to put up a wall
because the people that could
reap the benefit of more
democracy cannot reach our countries.
So, we actually promote democracy
and blame them for having
believed us at the same time.
It's a terrible paradox that
brings me back to the two lines
that I've read you of
the European Union Treaty
because if we truly
believe in human dignity
and human rights, then
somewhere there must be
not a compromise, but a balance between
the need of security and recognition
that human beings have a right to move,
including cross borders.
Otherwise, that doesn't work.
Our narrative is failed.
Your reference to these two
persons that look like actors,
I think you're right. (laughs)
Look like actors.
These two persons actually
are actors in the sense that
possibly they do not truly
believe in what they say.
Because if they believed in it,
then they should show how
their own lives are in conformity
with the principles that they
pronounce are invaluable.
I fear that we, if you
had the time to test them,
they would've failed to pass that test,
because these are normally
people who talk about values,
but do not actually implement them.
Because if they implement
being, for example,
a whole-hearted Catholic,
how can they make all
these people prisoners
for months with no respect on the law?
Why, how can they push them back to Libya?
It's a hell place to be
without any right there.
And we all know that.
How?
So, there is a part of acting,
but that hides behind a
clear contradiction between
steady principles and
actually performance,
execution in practice of
those values that are claimed.
So I [Indistinct]
- Actually, about this distillment,
there is something that can be
somehow interesting to share.
Because in order to keep the documentary
a bit more balanced, we had to
cut parts that were much more
extreme in their expression.
Basically, we kept the balanced
parts of what they said
of, I mean, there were parts where this
man was saying that this
political era is unfit
for example, that we didn't
put into the documentary
because this, the idea of the documentary,
of all my work and all of our work is
to keep the documentary
balanced enough so that
it's clear, our position.
But there is also enough space for them
to express themselves.
And we believe that their
ideas don't need any comment,
because they speak for themselves badly.
But we, for example,
decided to not push too much
and to not put, for example,
these other fiddler declaration
because we had the sensation
that this way we would
unbalance a bit too much the documentary.
We wanted to keep, to give
the audience a note about,
also these two men.
I must say that I kind of
agree when you say that I'm not
totally sure if they truly
believe in what they say
and I am not talking
about them specifically.
There is a component,
a political component
that we can categorize as
nationalists far right,
that it's difficult to
believe that they truly,
that they will truly
stick to the principles
that they claim to believe in.
Of course they talk a lot and they do that
also in the documentary,
but clearly day by day,
they direct another way.
For example, we decided to
use this part when they say
that he is a Catholic and
they say a lot of times
that he is against abortion.
And that in these political discourse
there is a lot of,
there are a lot of words
for God, which when you,
when you think about what
he's saying, it sounds crazy.
So he is saying,
he is saying the worst things
ever about human beings.
But there is a,
that is very Catholic and
we come again there too,
a bit the contradiction,
the human contradiction that
constantly comes with this,
with people that take these,
they come from these political,
political components that come again from,
the effects of the phenomenon.
I would like to to say
something about this last word
that I say, phenomenon.
I also, we were also
discussing this before.
Clearly, and we should also
say there are responsibility,
different responsibilities.
The documentary gives some means about
where these responsibilities lay,
and it is important, for
me the word phenomenon
because one of the main issues
is that in the last 11 years,
we've been talking all the
time of emergency and crisis
and to use the word problem,
which is very wrong.
Because this is not a
problem, this is a phenomenon.
So, one of the issues is
that if we continue when,
if we continue to address
this issue as a problem,
we will look for a solution and of course,
we will not find a solution,
because this is not a problem.
I always do the example
that if we will find,
if we'll try to do to
find a solution for rain,
we'll never find a solution.
We will continue to get
out of our apartment
when it's raining and we
will continue to have rain
coming in grass.
But if we were consider this a phenomenon,
we will not find, we will
not look for a solution.
We will look for something
to manage the phenomenon.
In case of the rain, we'll get a raincoat,
we'll get an umbrella,
we will find a way to
manage the phenomenon,
which is the same thing that we should do
with the migration.
It's not a problem, it's a phenomenon.
It's something that's always separate,
always the human being is a migrant,
and this is not never gonna stop.
And the only goal that we are reaching by
addressing this as a problem
is fueling the political
discourse that we've been
seeing in this documentary.
- [Speaker] I have a question
about another contradiction,
probably.
You have this woman
speaking about insecurity.
Can you be, give a bit
of the background of her
because I might have gotten that wrong,
but is she also one of the, I mean,
is she a migrant herself or yeah?
- It's a very, it's a
very interesting question.
Also the fact that you might have thought
that she's a migrant,
that she's a Maltese.
She's speaking Maltese and we've been,
we've been looking for
somebody speaking Maltese
to put in the documentary because again,
this was a clear contradiction
of what they were saying.
So, basically this woman was
talking against people coming
from Africa and Arab countries,
speaking a language which is Maltese,
that clearly sounds Arab.
Because it's a mixture of
different languages where Arab,
in terms of sound-
- 40% is Arabic.
- Definitely, definitely as as a pointer.
And she's part of this nationalist
organization that also,
the other two men talk
and what her parties,
it's a minor part in the
documentary, but it's very,
it's very important because
explain perfectly and
graphically one of the
issues that we have in Malta
not just in Malta, Malta
is stronger because
it's incredible that she
speaks a language which is 40%
Arabic and that she also looks Arabic
and that she feel this distance with
the people arriving from
countries that clearly contributed
to build the place where she
lives now, where she's from.
- Maybe, finally on my side,
an additional level of complexity
and a problem that your
documentary raises so skillfully,
it is the notion of migrant.
We discussed this before
starting the screening
and but your, actually, your
work shows it perfectly well.
There is this logic of
migrants as a category.
All these people that come from outside,
they're all migrants.
What does that mean?
Nobody understands it.
The only thing that defines them is that
they entered some way illegally.
Again, if you are drowning
at sea and you are saved,
you are not illegal.
Not at all.
The law says the opposite.
Actually in Malta, it's very
difficult to enter the country
illegally, (laughs)
because unless you reach the
coast with your own boat,
which is very, very difficult,
normally you are saved at
sea and brought to the island
and in that situation
you are a legal migrant.
Cause you are the right to be saved.
Then the question of what if you,
if you have a right to
remain in the island,
that's a separate matter,
but why is it separate?
Because in the discourse,
the logic of migrant
catch-all definition hides
the other one, which is mosques,
the word mosque is repeated
three or four times.
So it hides actually Muslim.
Many of these poor
persons come, for example,
from Ethiopia that is a Christian country.
Several people that come
from Sudan are Christians.
There is a sizable minority
in Egypt of Christians.
How can one simply looking at
a person that has black skin
decide that that is a
migrant equal to Muslim?
That comes from a label that
is attached to their face.
And it goes even further, because they say
that this one of the last
interviews with this person,
young person, I understand
is it [Indistinct]
He says, "They don't let me stay here.
There is no future here.
Don't try, don't try to come here."
Because they will kill
you on the road in Libya,
one understands the dangers through sparse
bits and pieces of sentences.
But he says also "I would
like to have a family here,
but I am black."
So, the second unspoken reason is racist.
Is the color of the skin.
This is the second I spoke.
So behind the word migrant hides,
again I come back to my
article of the treaty
of the European Union,
is the denial of the human
dignity as an individual
because we simply don't
look at the person,
we look at the image we
think that person projects
and if that person comes from Africa
and that person happens
to be a black person,
automatically that is a
migrant to be rejected
because it means Muslim
and different from me.
So, this is what I felt very strongly.
So there is in my view, an
urgency to fight against this
direct laboring that
has become omnipresent
and is fueling the
extreme right discourse.
- There is something
integrated in this direction
I would like to add
and it is a way, the
soul of the documentary.
The documentary we try
to work on the distance
between again, the perception
that the society has
on migration and the reality.
And we saw this very
clearly in this documentary.
So there is a construction
of an idea of invasion
and difference and distance and migrants
and not human being coming
from another planet.
While the reality is that we
are just talking of persons,
human beings like us.
I always make this example which is,
I don't know if you're familiar with
the geographical position of Sicily,
but I would try to explain
to you for a moment.
Sicily, which is one of the
southest parts of Europe,
as it's southest point, it's
actually southern to Indonesia.
And the difference between
a person that was born
in the south of Sicily and
the person that was born in
Indonesia, it's just the passport.
It's nothing, it's not
a right that I acquired
because I am particularly
intelligent or because I am,
I did something for this.
I just was born in a place
that gave me a passport,
that gave me the possibility
to travel wherever I want.
And then a person which is by boat,
just two hours from my coast
has a different passport
and is alive, is a
nightmare if want to travel.
So, we are talking about people
that share the same thing.
One of these count of these
areas, Sicily is a bit southern,
the other one I have a
passport to give me the chance
to travel wherever I want as
another Mauro, 39 years old,
Indonesia, has a much more miserable life
just because he was
born a bit of southern.
When we think about this,
realize that our policy,
in terms of migration
is grounded on something
that is absolutely unacceptable,
which has no humanity at all.
And when we just think about
policy of Italian governments
and many other governments in Europe,
also northern countries
that don't take resolutions
in order to make this kind
of phenomenon something
that is managed with one only
thing managed is solidarity.
It's incredible.
It's incredible that in
2022, we are still discussing
and talking about the
way that we should work
in this phenomenon, about
what we should to do,
you know it is clear.
It's not particularly complicated.
It's complicated on the political
side maybe to find a way,
but on the [Indistinct] side,
this should not be so
complicated to understand.
It's just that we slowly
became prisoners of these
perceptions of ourselves based on nothing.
Just because we were born in
a country instead of another,
which is something that
can't define the rights
that we have.
It's incredible that rights are different
if you're born in Italy or
if you're born in Indonesia.
It doesn't make any sense,
but this is what it is.
- [Speaker] Can I ask about,
there is one scene with the students,
I'm not very clear, but is
there intentions from your side
showing that, because those
two are like working students.
So, what is it that you
would like to convey
in that kinda particular scene?
Especially when he's also
talking about these different
people trying to contact him
to come to Malta and he's,
he understands himself as
someone could not encourage
people from there to come.
He's so well aware what,
how he situated himself,
like, "I can't be too welcoming.
I can also be realistic about this."
Is there a particular side or something
that you wanted to show?
- Yeah, the idea, first
of all, for example,
we decided to not alter the
titles, the country of origin
because we didn't want
to put another label,
we didn't do for all the
other people interviewed.
We didn't put Italy, Malta
and we didn't want do that
with the refugees.
So, this was a specific choice
that we didn't do very simply
in the other two previous documentaries.
The third part of the trilogy that we,
the other documentaries, we decided.
And the idea was to, we tried,
we strongly tried to give an
image of the refugees as less
emotional as we could.
Usually in this kind of contents,
the image of the refugees that we see
inevitably also because of the
context are very emotional,
are images that you,
you see a documentary and
sometimes you can't help
but to cry because their
stories and their conditions
are difficult.
We wanted to completely
change this narrative
in this documentary,
not because we wanted to
deny their [Indistinct]
but because we wanted to
show something completely
different.
That's why we, for
example, you mentioned it,
we put working student, not just refugee
because we wanted to make clear that these
are human beings that are
trying to live in this country
to study and to work at a
cost of enormous sacrifices
because it's not easy at all.
So the idea was to humanize
them as much as possible,
trying to put them out
of this categorization
that inevitably we put them in
when we look at them in
context like refugee camps
or when they just arrived
after three days trip
in the Mediterranean.
But to give to the audience
the perception that
these are not Maltese.
In 10 years, awfully these
are Maltese working, living.
And that's also why we wanted
to close the documentary
with this young guy saying,
"Actually, don't come.
This is difficult."
Because again, the
narrative usually is like,
"Come, it's easy." It's not like that.
And actually when you work for a while
on the subject of migration
in this part of the world,
which I lived now for more than 10 years,
you realize story after story,
that a very small minority of these people
really wanted to come to Europe.
They've been forced to come to Europe.
It's something to come out
many times in the documentary.
But I had the possibility
to experience very well.
It's you, Lucio was was
talking a bit of Arab Springs,
which is of course the,
they say the starting of
a very important historical point for
all these migrations thing.
And when the war started in Libya,
there are millions of Africans
from everywhere in Africa,
working in Libya that have
absolutely no interest
in coming to Europe,
that are working in Libya
and getting salaries
that most of the times
are better than the ones
that we get in Sicily and
they are not thinking at all
to come to Europe.
Of course, to make clear,
I'm not defending Gaddafi,
but it is to say that-
- That was the situation.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It is a fact.
- A lot of mostly the people that we,
that arrive in Europe and I
would say, I know a bit less,
but I would say that
probably is the same in the
United States.
People arrive in the
United States will probably
prefer to just stay at
home with the family
in their country of origin.
It just, it's not always possible.
And this documentary shows
it from another side,
a side to try to humanize
as much as possible,
the human being.
- [Speaker] I think that
I understood at least one,
maybe two of the speakers,
to express an opinion
that the European Union
was not sufficient in its policies.
Am I right that both of those speakers,
or the one if there was only one,
was in fact Maltese and not migrant?
But it's an interesting question,
what they think should be
better about European Union's
policy in so far as it exists
and whether what they expect to improve
should legitimately be hoped for,
or whether they're just dreaming
about something that couldn't be better,
that is realistically
not likely to happen.
- I would say something about this
and then I will to leave us all to Lucio,
who has very important
experience about this.
Actually one of the, I suppose
that you're talking about
the woman that is speaking in Italian,
she's the director of an NGO
that is rescuing people between
in the Mediterranean.
And talking about there are many things
that European citizenship could do better,
I will address one of them.
I will leave to Lucio, that
has a lot of experience
again about this, which
is the Dublin convention.
Under this rule, which
is a European Union rule,
when a human being, let's
try to use this word,
when a human being reach
Europe is allowed to
ask for asylum just in
the country of arrival
and not in another country.
So, if a migrant arrived in Malta
can ask for a political
asylum just in Malta,
cannot travel to Italy or
to Germany or to France
or either cannot ask for
asylum in France from Malta
to France from Malta, can
just do that in Malta.
This is a huge problem for
many reasons, first of all.
Because of course, the
southern countries of Europe
have this problem, actually
this amount of responsibility
in comparison with the
northern countries of Europe.
But also because, mostly of course,
the human beings arriving
don't want to stay
in the south part of
Europe and would like to go
in the northern part of Europe.
And also because in the
specific case of Malta,
you can can probably
imagine that very easily.
Most of the human beings
arriving in Malta,
they don't know what Malta is.
Of course, they took a
boat from the North Africa,
thinking they would reach
Europe and they end in Malta,
which is a very small island
in the middle of the Mediterranean.
They didn't know it existed,
they didn't know it's a country.
It's- can you imagine?
They are there and they're stuck there.
They basically can't move from there.
They can't go anywhere else.
They can either get an
asylum, political asylum there
or move back, which add
another layer of problems
to what they say.
And I will leave it to Lucio, who
definitely has something
to say about this.
- Maybe I will try to
be systematic but short,
because this is a huge question
you are raising, actually.
First, you said in so
far as there is a policy,
don't get me, don't be mistaken.
There is a policy.
Europe, the European Union has
deployed a significant force
of protection of the
border called Frontex,
which is very, very powerful.
It is mentioned in the documentary.
Frontex what is Frontex?
Frontex is a quasi-federalized agency
that complements the control
of the external voters
of the Union in the areas that
have particular difficulties
that are now widespread.
Because with the recent Belarus crisis,
then we have it in the Baltics,
we have them down in
Bulgaria versus Turkey.
We have them in Greece,
we have them in Italy and Malta,
and now also in the Canary Islands,
because of the crossings from Morocco.
So you see that this is now spread around,
we are talking about numbers
that are becoming serious.
Over 10,000 men and women
permanently employed
and they have a couple of
billions of viewers available,
which is equal to a couple
of billions of dollars.
So although it's not huge numbers,
it becomes a serious number.
And that makes a difference.
They are patrolling,
they dispose of the best
equipment in terms of
satellite control.
They use the same kind of
satellite systems that the
military and the Navy of
NATO uses in Mediterranean.
They're sharing the
same kind of equipment.
So they are extremely sophisticated,
close to what you see with
the homeland securities
that has been developed here.
And that's a policy.
So, that was not existent 10 years ago.
The sacrosanct protection of
the frontures of your country
that was considered by
the patriots to be in
for the countries, you
know, European Union,
nothing to do.
And no, all the extremists
or less extremists of Europe
are now behind the existence of a federal
European Union policy
concerned with Frontex.
But when it comes to a
federal, quasi-federal approach
to the influx of these human beings
that is generically labeled as migrants,
then there it disappears.
Why?
Because the main drive there
is what you have heard
in this documentary,
protection of your country means
protection of your culture,
protection of your customs,
protection of your religion.
Hence, each states keeps it to itself.
So the Dublin,
the Dublin treaty or Dublin agreement,
which is now translated into
European Union regulations,
it's actually very progressive in terms of
asylum-seeking rights.
There is a wealth of legislation
that is actually very progressive.
And I can state without
exaggerating that it is
one of the most progressive in the world.
The problem is the limitation
that Mauro is indicating.
So, what is lacking is
exactly that, crossing.
We like having a federalized
police at the border.
We don't like having a federalized policy
of distributing the people,
because the problem is not with the
moment when you disembark.
Somebody should know if that
person embarking in Malta,
it's Malta taking care
of the identification
and providing or not the
status of refugee, for example.
All right?
That could be perfectly
okay, provided that Malta
is not stuck with all these
people that do not go anywhere.
So, the redistribution.
And redistribution hits the
wall of this kind of discourse
that you have heard in the documentary.
Yes, and I unfortunately have
to say is the same debate
that you have here in the
United States, identical.
I can mention one person,
although I don't know if this
is caution enough or not,
but if I mention Mr. Bannon, Steve Bannon,
you may have heard of him,
former aide of Mr. Trump.
He was pursuing the same
policies in Europe throughout.
He is called as a guru by certain quarters
in European politics.
There is a clear direct
connection even through the
same persons on the two
sides of the Atlantic.
So, we are confronted to a generational,
cultural and therefore,
political issue here.
And sorry to come back
to my starting point
of this exchange,
human dignity and human
rights are individual.
We cannot dispose of groups of
people undefined as migrants
and keep them like parcels
in a warehouse somewhere
in one country or the other.
And that we need to solve.
We must solve it. It's unsustainable.
- [Speaker] Can I follow up?
So what happens when they are in Malta?
So, we're talking about
like the government
stuck with people not there
and that, so I just, this is-
- What happens?
- [Speaker] What happened
after that, people are-
- Yeah, but what happens before also?
Because if you are in Malta
and you're stuck with all these people,
the question that you are
asking is what happens next?
If I am an asylum seeker
and I am given asylum status
because in my country, I cannot go back.
[Indistinct] and Ethiopia,
I mean, Sudan are clear examples.
You cannot push these people back.
Not only it's inhuman,
it's in violation of existing convention,
international conventions
like the refugee convention in
1951 of the UI, no?
So, we cannot do.
So, Malta is stuck with these people,
they must keep them.
So, what is the alternative for Malta?
Push back as many as possible because
we heard that as again,
we cannot get more,
which is not entirely correct,
because (laughs) this is a perception, no?
We are full.
Full of what? (laughs)
There is full of request of people working
and doing jobs that nobody takes in Malta
as much as in Italy and elsewhere.
But this idea that if we open
up the working opportunities.
Here I come with the word,
then you open up to a pull factor.
This is the word in politics in Europe
and also in this state, in this country.
Pull factor meaning you
actually incite people to come
because they will find work.
So, you don't give them anything.
So that it shows
exemplarily that you will,
it's useless to come.
So, what happens is before and after.
After, you keep them completely separated
to make it an example for the outside.
And before, you make it sure that you
take them the least possible,
including you, one creates
problems to the NGOs
that save people at sea.
This case I was involved
in had this judgment.
The first topic was exactly about that,
Italy putting all possible
obstacles to the NGOs
that save people at sea, why?
Because by doing that the
pull factor is diminished.
People should know that if they
try to cross, they will die.
So they don't come.
Nothing of that, neither before nor after,
seems to me in line with the principles.
They are not.
I think it is objective, it
is not a simple perception.
- Absolutely, and also,
to add something which is very better
but I think again we come
back to the same image.
It's important to insist.
You asked what happened when they,
after they arrived.
Basically one thing which
is one more time absurd.
There is an officer at some point deciding
if this human being traveled to Malta
as an economical migrant
or an asylum-seeker.
So, there is somebody from
an office deciding this.
There would be an interview
and they will even
check if you have scars,
if you have a psychological
situation that might be related
to some kind violence you suffered
in your country of origin.
And then after this interview,
and after the review of
your psychological case,
your physical case, the
country you're coming,
they will decide, okay,
you are traveling here
because there is a problem in your country
or you are traveling here just because
you want a better future.
The second case, you are
denied asylum of course.
Because to want a be future
is not enough to come here.
In the first case, if you
clearly show signs of problems
from your country of origin,
then you might be allowed to
stay with a status of refugee,
which then leads again
to all the complications
because when you got your refugee status,
this also important, but
this would be a very long
discussion, because sometimes
we had the sensation that
"Okay, you got your refugee status,
now your life is paradise"
is not exactly right.
Also, the refugee status actually,
that is not guaranteeing a
very necessarily happy life.
It's good, it's a good way to start
unless you have the
right to stay in Europe.
But still there are a lot of limitation
and a lot of criteria that
you continuously need to
reaffirm to stay.
- [Speaker] Okay. So, thank
you very much to both of you.
Lucio Gussetti, visiting fellow
at the European Studies Council
and to Mauro Mondello,
for your discussions.
Very fruitful discussions
that we had on the topic.
And I hope then to be
able to have you back
at another opportunity with your thoughts.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
(applause)